Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts, the FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us Ruffians today for our 51st episode!
Can you say that okay?
51st.
That's the right way, right?
The 51st episode!
BAU BAU!
51st.
Is that wrong?
I don't know, somehow it sounds wrong.
51st.
BAU BAU!
51st on December 1st.
Well, Ruffians, if you're just joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet all your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It kind of feels like, you know, it's a new month.
Feels like a new week, but it's not.
Are you warmed up for today?
I'm warmed up.
Do you feel a bit cold?
I do, actually.
I say I'm warmed up.
I do feel a bit cold, a bit... Yeah, the bones don't quite move as smoothly.
It's the somber first, you know?
It's a bit chilly, huh?
That is why Moco-chan did any Ruffians see Peroncino.
Let's see!
Do we have Pero Sighting?
De-den!
It is Pero.
It's a Pero Sighting.
At first I thought someone had broken into your very nice looking car there.
It's just Pero.
Yeah.
Just Pero.
It would be really awful if your window was smashed, you know?
But that's not uncommon in the big cities, right?
Right?
Yeah, but... At least you know Pero is just sleeping.
Just sleeping.
I feel like he's the best when he's knocked out cold in a deep slumber, you know?
Yeah.
He almost kind of looks cute.
Even a bit curly.
Ruffians, do you think so too?
Not so cool.
Oh, like sleeping.
Like a... Not cuddly, you agree!
Well, that's interesting, but... You wouldn't go down, why?
You would never cuddle Pero.
Probably best for your own safety.
But you know, I think it's probably best that you let him sleep undisturbed there, you know?
You won't like him if you wake him up before he's ready.
You know, he's kinda like Fuwawa when you accidentally wake him up.
This way to the sink.
Hopefully, though, he went on his way once he was rested up and, you know, there was no damage to your car or anything.
Unless, you know, maybe you decided to chop him in there.
What?
Thank you!
Thank you for letting us know that you saw Pero!
He had a good sleep, yeah.
But, you know, maybe he should be working a little bit harder, huh?
BAU BAU!
Well, you can't just be sleeping like that in other places, okay?
Well, in happier news, we actually have something great!
Ruffians!
We've been breaking a lot of milestones recently.
Almost every FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
Well, this time, we hit 300,000 followers on Twitter!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for making Twitter a fun place, Ruffians.
We hope that you know that maybe we've been able to make it a fun place for you too.
We hope that we can do more fun things, more Twitter spaces, and even some more silly tweets in the future.
We love it when you respond to us and are just silly and kind with other Ruffians there.
Thank you so much for making it a wonderful community.
Please, please look forward to our next Rhyme Response 2!
Can you do a Rhyme Response?
This one.
Go looking for it.
You Ruffians, you respond to us, and we respond to you!
Moco-chan.
I wonder when that will be.
Maybe soon.
Well, no spoilers.
But here's to hoping that we're able to connect with you even more through the power of Twitter.
BAU BAU!
Not Howl and Hunt.
Not today.
Not tomorrow.
We'll give you more warning before that.
Not today!
Not tomorrow!
What is it?
I don't know.
Oh.
Sometimes.
BAU BAU!
Now there's been more updates on Ruffians!
Actually, you know, we're still puppies.
Still puppies.
Puppies are new dogs.
New dogs can do new tricks.
And so, we tried something new, Ruffians!
Finally, after a long time of trying and just not having enough time and kind of forgetting.
Forgetting, maybe a bit of a lot of forgetting.
We made our first post on Reddit!
Yeah!
Reddit, that's the website!
On the hololive Reddit.
There's us going BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Yeah!
Thank you for welcoming us there to Ruffians, okay?
Redditor Ruffians!
We know you so much!
You know, we still don't really know too much about Reddit.
We hope to be able to interact with you and other hololive fans there in the future!
And you know, also see a
Maybe what you're up to sometimes.
While we're at it.
So you might see us around there.
Just maybe.
Maybe making posts.
Maybe commenting.
But for Reddit we don't really get it still.
Somehow Ruffians, thanks to your very warm welcome, it seems like we made it to all on Reddit.
I don't know, but somehow we got almost a million views!
It seems pretty crazy.
One million people here!
Let's BAU BAU!
Right, right!
Maybe that means we were some people's first exposure to Vtubers the other day.
Maybe!
That would be funny, huh?
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Well, we hope that if we were their first, you know, that they thought we were neat.
And, you know, if they didn't, well, we hope that they found something else on Reddit that they also thought was neat.
Yeah!
You know,
Ruffians, we're going to do our best there.
Hopefully we don't make any silly mistakes or anything.
If we do, we do.
Can we make reddit mistakes?
I don't know.
If we do, we do.
We're looking forward to having lots of fun there too!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU can't wait for episode 75 of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for looking forward to it.
You're gonna have to wait a little bit.
BAU BAU!
Well, there's been more exciting things.
Because as you know, Ruffians, it's officially December 1st!
It is.
That means it's the last month of the year.
Indeed.
We hope it's been a great year for you, but Ruffians, if maybe you feel like you need a little bit more cheer, especially holiday cheer, we have just the thing!
hololive English Abbey Calendar is back this year!
It's back!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
And of course, the video has already been revealed!
You know, we have Kiara-senpai there looking mighty.
Santa.
Ruffians.
We also have some very, uh, we have very, very cute thumbnails by Pongsamori!
But you know, there'll be something new and special every day for you unveiled at 4pm PT leading up to Christmas.
And you know, as FUWAMOCO, we were actually a part of the first video in the advent calendar.
Did you see it?
We sung a silly song with Kiara-senpai and Calli-senpai and Nerissa!
Yeah, Fuwawa.
If you haven't checked it out yet, please do!
You liked it!
Thank you!
It was very silly.
It was.
Please go check it out at holoen-abyss.com.
That's holoen-abyss.com.
Alvin.com.
And that way you can view the Alvin calendar.
Please don't forget to click through the days to look at the previous videos too.
I think if you go now it'll be like day 2 and it won't have a video.
But you just need to click.
Go to day 1 and you can see the video.
Otherwise you have to wait until 4pm.
You don't want to wait all the time, huh?
But it'll be a lot of fun!
Okay, so don't miss them.
Got it?
Why don't you, maybe, I know maybe it's not good.
Maybe you might get in trouble, but you could leave the tab open.
And you know, refresh every day for a new video.
That's a good idea, Mococo-chan.
You don't have a lot of tabs open, right Ruffians?
Right.
Right, good idea.
Smart thinking.
I don't have a lot of tabs open either.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
And we also made our first appearance on the official hololive English YouTube channel the other day with Kiara-senpai, Calli-senpai, and IRyS-senpai.
Because...
Well, we wanted to talk about the hololive English Concert, Connect the World that happened in LA during the summer.
And, uh, well, Ruffians, did you watch it?
It was before, a little bit before Alvin debuted.
You know, Alvin was actually even teased first at that concert.
You did!
You remember that?
If you haven't watched the concert yet, it's good.
It's good still because you still have that chance, that extra special chance.
But, well, in fact for us it was a very very special concert so we are really happy to be able to
Share our feelings and our thoughts on it, especially with all our other senpai you know.
And you know we also made a very special announcement!
Yeah!
There will be a BLUE RAY RELEASE!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU RELEASE!
It's really, really amazing, right?
We're so lucky, Ruffians!
You know, a lot of hard work goes into making the physical releases like this.
So we hope that you'll want to get your paws on it.
And maybe, you know, one day, if Advent gets to perform at a hololive English Concert... Again?
Again?
Not again.
Someday!
Not again!
You know.
That there will be a physical release on it so that we can watch it over and over and over and treasure all the moments forever and ever.
That would be nice.
It's a lot of hoping.
We'll be waiting too!
Thank you!
But, guess what?
You don't need to wait for the blu-ray to connect the world.
Although maybe you do a little bit, but...
It's coming so very soon!
And if you happen to watch the stream of the concert live too, on the Blu-ray there are different camera angles and name changes made too, so I'm sure that you'll find new things that surprise you too!
Lots of things to enjoy!
BAU BAU!
Very exciting.
Who would think a Blu-ray release?
Well, Ruffians, the next... Well, it's sort of exciting.
This is crazy!
Sort of crazy.
Mind-blowing.
Mind-boggling.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well, Ruffians, you know how we played hololive Suica, right?
Because there was a big update!
Like the DM members, ID members, and FUWAMOCO too!
But, Mumei-senpai!
She was playing Holosuika before bed.
You know, something that we often do too, but look.
Look at this.
Not only did she get over 10k, but she broke 15,000!
That's absolutely bonkers.
Bonkers.
How did she do it?
I mean, I think you... It's kind of that solid foundation that she has at the bottom, you know, with the Fuwawas and the Mococos near each other, right?
Yeah, it's very definitely the key to that.
Yeah, it's because of the beautiful harmony that only we can create as twin sisters.
The harmony that we provide.
She was able to create such an amazing score.
Definitely, definitely.
Yes, we built up the amazing score for her, that's for sure.
It's a strong base, right?
Well, I hope that Mumei-senpai had fun.
That it was a good game.
Maybe this is it.
We're giving up on getting the highest score in hololive English.
I don't think we can even get close to that.
I guess Mumei-senpai, you can have it.
She deserves it.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
No, you guys don't do it!
Thank you for believing in us!
That's very nice.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations, Ruby Senpai!
That's amazing.
It's crazy.
I don't know if I believe it.
I know, I was kind of thinking, Ruby Senpai's pretty smart, maybe.
But no.
But no, she didn't do anything wrong.
Naughty.
She didn't do anything naughty, okay?
No.
Yeah.
On this topic, nice to do FUWAMOCO!
Because Ruffians, it's a new month.
It's a new month.
A new month and we're definitely starting it off on the right paw.
Yeah.
Cause you know,
We're FUWAMOCO!
So we're happy to announce that we'll be starting the summer off with... No Misunderstandings!
This is very very accurate, as always.
The majority of days have no misunderstandings.
This is how it goes.
Every day.
Let's make sure that we do well, that we have no misunderstandings this month at all, and that way, Yagoo Santa-san will visit us this year, okay?
Okay, Ruffians?
You're part of this too, okay?
We want Yagoo Santa-san to visit you, right?
Right.
Yes.
I thought you would be excited!
I guess Ruffians don't have that kind of aspirations, huh?
What if we want Yagoo-san to visit us?
Are you gonna help?
Help us with no misunderstandings!
Ho ho ho, sou desu ne.
You're not helping the misunderstandings, Fuwawa!
I didn't do anything wrong!
Huh?
We want to be on the good list.
Yeah.
Are we on the good list?
Or are we naughty puppies?
Which hololive members are on the back?
Ruffians.
Yes?
What does that mean?
Yes!
I don't think there's a misunderstanding here because it says right there.
Days without misunderstandings.
One.
Okay?
Yeah.
Yagoo-san desai is gonna be here, okay?
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU, PREPARE!
Well, Mococo-chan, let's go to our regular corner.
Starting with our Doggie of the Day!
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
We have... De-den!
WALL-E!
WALL-E FOR SHORT!
I want to hug his face.
He's like, this is his expression.
I just wanted to take his face and flop it all around, you know?
He looks like he could fly.
He's this Ruffian's cousin's dog, and apparently he's very friendly and naughty.
That's a good combination.
But which list is he going to be on?
The best one.
He loves playing with people and running around too.
I kind of want to ruff house with him.
I want to hear him go BAU BAU BAU!
I want to play growl with him.
It would be good.
I think it would be fun!
Very cute.
How does Wally bow bow?
I think it's sort of a deep bow.
BAU.
I think it's like a BAU.
What?
It sounds like a frog.
Don't make fun of Wally!
That's not how he sounds!
That's rude, Moco-chan!
Well, I think Wally looks like the kind of friend that you really want to go on adventures with.
A doggie that will definitely make you laugh and paint lots of memorable moments together with.
Especially since he likes to be naughty sometimes too.
Memorable in a good way.
Being naughty is okay because I think sometimes we all like to be a bit naughty too.
It makes for a silly and fun life, right?
Hi.
Even though you know Yago Santa-san needs to visit us too, so we gotta make sure that we're okay.
Well, we better prepare too, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, I'm feeling pretty chilly right now, but how are the ruffians doing?
You're not feeling too chilly?
How are your walks?
How are the walks going?
Let's see!
Today I went on a walk.
Where did this ruffian go for a walk?
De-den!
That's winking.
It looks so real!
It's so beautiful!
I don't know, somehow this photo looks both very cold and extremely warm at the same time.
Don't you think, Moco-chan?
No, I think it just looks very, very cold.
Not warm.
I hope that you're very, very well bundled up though.
I can imagine how my toes would feel if they feel like they are right now.
Well, hopefully you had some good snow boots and some mittens and everything on, some big fluffy socks.
FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO socks!
And maybe some goggles too!
Please make sure to stay warm, okay?
And be safe as well.
Thank you.
Thank you for sending us a little look into your world!
BAU BAU!
I think we got another question today.
Let's check out our Question of the Day!
We have... De-den!
Good morning, FUWAMOCO!
Good morning!
I was checking some old, old, old anime songs on YouTube and saw a video with romaji lyrics in it, very nostalgic.
Out of curiosity, here's my question.
When you perform slash sing JP songs during karaoke, do you use lyrics in romaji format?
This is actually a very good question.
A very good question.
Especially since our Rock n' Rawr party is tomorrow!
Yeah!
Well, the answer is it really depends.
Yeah, I guess the most preferred format for us is a video with timed lyrics in Japanese and furigana, which is like little hiragana on top of the complicated kanji.
Because, you know, it's helpful.
But a lot of times, we don't get that.
So we have to go source our own lyrics, and that's where sometimes it gets a bit rough.
I know.
Again, it's most preferred if it's in Japanese, but sometimes you need furigana because for us, we need to be able to know how it's right at a glance, you know, because we're gonna sing it any second, you know?
But for example, it can get tricky because there's like, ashita, tomorrow, right?
The kanji for tomorrow.
It could be ashita or asu.
Same as like iku and yuku.
It's small things but it's important.
I know it's happened before, but sometimes when we source our lyrics, there are mistakes in them.
And somebody read the lyrics wrong, or maybe a whole section is gone.
We try to check them over beforehand, but sometimes we run out of time.
It's tricky, I know it.
We do our best though, but sometimes we have to get a bit resourceful too.
A lot of preparation.
That's right.
It's a lot of preparation that's not actually practicing.
We know that.
It can be tricky, but it's fun.
The brain has to go pretty fast.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the question.
Thank you Ruffians for your submissions today too.
Ruffians, we're always looking for more Doggy of the Days for your Pero Sighting, for your walks even though it's cold out, for your questions too!
Do your best!
So if anything comes to mind, please use the hashtag, hashtag FWMCMORNING and let us know, okay?
Yeah, don't hesitate!
BAU BAU!
Now for our next stream!
We have...
De-den!
Tonight!
We're having a comfy movie night together with all of Abbot over on Shiori's channel.
Comfy.
Yeah, look at us on the sofa, there's comfy.
But this time we're watching her movie pick, which is a movie called The Silence of the Lambs.
I think that it's probably best not to bring snacks.
Save those for later, okay?
Yeah, concern for the doggos, thank you!
I'm not too sure what to expect, but I'm kinda concerned too.
Every movie is a bit concerned, right?
A bit concerning.
Yeah, but I'm sure it'll be eventful just like every movie night has been, right?
Yeah, it's been fun.
If it's with Abyss, it's definitely fine.
BAU BAU!
And if we take a peek at our schedule, we have De-den!
Well, tomorrow we're having another Rock n' Rawr Party!
This time,
Extra Special!
Ruffians, we haven't announced the theme yet, right?
We haven't, no.
So maybe we should?
Oh, yeah.
Well, Ruffians, you've heard of 2.5D idols, right?
Have you?
Why?
2.5D.
Wow!
Actually, this time we're going to be singing Only Love Live at Idolmas!
BAU BAU!
The two worlds come together in a perfect idol harmony this time!
Let's have lots of fun.
Excited!
Let's have lots of fun singing all the classics and the hit songs too.
Make sure you do, okay?
We're gonna
Start a happy party train and go my FUWAMOCO!
Go my way!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us for today's 51st episode!
Our first FUWAMOCO Morning in December.
51st.
I don't know why it still sounds weird, huh?
But, Ruffians, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Ellipsis!
BAU BAU!
Happy!
Orange Juice!
BAU BAU!
Zeiss!
Yellow!
BAU BAU!
Homies of PA!
Panda Remix!
BAU BAU!
Fuji!
Afutotake!
BAU BAU!
Yakumo Yomi!
And to every other ruffian out there,
We hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!